[Música]
y en color y technicolor porque la
tecnología está avanzando entonces por
facebook live youtube y nuestro sitio
rc y net punto sea paloma leonora
leonardo bienvenidos a todos todos y un
caluroso saludo a todos los que nos
están escuchando y oyendo el domingo no
nos oyen los que escuchan el programa en
nuestro sitio internet y les agradecemos
por su agradable compañía un placer
estar con ustedes y este bueno antes de
darle rienda suelta al castor
cibernético de hoy no sé si tienen
alguna noticia o algo insólito yo tengo
algo además que tiene como un aspecto
que pues justamente por eso me gustó de
generosidad es un canadiense de halifax
de nueva escocia que le gusta mucho
jugar al póker
y este canadiense que se llama scott y
huelen bajo tiene como trabajo es un
traductor de textos budistas y bueno
como digo su hobby es jugar al póker y
ganó casi un millón de dólares
canadienses y los donó completamente a
obras de caridad bueno él debe estar muy
bien entonces me imagino financieramente
el vino no no lo que él dice es que él
en el panel el juego el póker es un
placer muy grande y que los dioses entre
comillas lo ayudan porque ya no es la
primera vez que gana y dona su dinero
cada vez que gana participó en otro
torneo torneo de póker en españa y ganó
95 mil dólares
el tono también inmediatamente y él dice
que por eso gana porque como es
traductor budista y cree en estas cosas
pues entonces te dice que sí sí sí
guarda el dinero para él va a dejar va a
empezar a perder
entonces se después de todo totalmente
todo entonces me pareció algo insólito y
además pues muy interesante grande
yo tampoco nos comenzaría por pagar
todas las deudas que algún premio
insólito
pero que en realidad me dio un poquito
de miedo en el fondo el technology en su
revista publicó un artículo antes de
ayer diciendo que se están haciendo hace
rato que se hacen injertos de células
madre cerebrales en animales y me cuesta
el cerebro humano un animal de han
descubierto que se alumbran zonas que se
alumbran cuando el hombre hace uso de la
consciencia en el animal en el animal
entonces el animal tiene conciencia de
nosotros y probablemente en la tiene
pero no está desarrollada como un ser
humano dijo
gallina chancho que trasplante al
corazón del chancho al ser humano y le
pasamos nuestro cerebro eso sería una
desgracia para la humanidad total
el chancho con nuestros cerebros
no lo podemos decir al aire pero después
se la cuento con papel chancho
no nos dicen dicen que el chancho si nos
dicen que el chancho tiene orgasmos de
30 minutos ah caramba
imagínate que lo transplante
a eso
de leonardo fíjate lo que es la vida
hablábamos de trasplantes de corazón de
los humanos
porque cuando vea que lo vayan llevando
al matadero entonces él alumbra por ahí
algo
el otro día leí un artículo sobre un
libro de reciente el libro que habla
justamente de una época de ciencia
ficción 20 años no lo que habla de
se habla de una época donde no se puede
comer más animales porque los animales
no no no no hay una contaminación
animales opciones de comer más animal
entonces empiezan a generar o no el
riego de comidas y generan
cuerpos humanos para consumo humano
es un libro crítica decía que si es un
uno que va a leer es una persona
sensible que no es recomendable porque
las imágenes que describe ese libro son
imágenes su hogar estos seres humanos
que producen seres humanos para ser
consumidos tienen alguna característica
especial tal vez le sacan el cerebro los
producen sin cerebro uno
ahora tú lo escoge este apoyo
que te permita comerlos sin cargo de
conciencia a eso me refiero
en realidad no es nada insólito pero es
algo que me hizo feliz de alguna manera
porque es un par de chicas y nuits del
lejano norte canadiense que produjeron
una película sobre los cantos de
garganta de los que entonces son unas
chicas que de niñas iban perdiendo esta
tradición porque no se las iban
enseñando y finalmente decidieron de
adolescentes comenzará a practicar este
estos cantos de garganta juntas y
después producir una película que cuenta
la historia de su aprendizaje y cuente
su relación con él con él con los viejos
de la comunidad con el medio ambiente
con la naturaleza y no solamente
produjeron esta maravillosa película
sino además fueron escogidos escogidas
las dos y las dos y su película
para el festival sundance
de documentales entonces creo que es un
gran logro para esta chica porque
tenemos que decirle a nuestros oyentes y
a los que nos están viviendo en este
momento que el canto de garganta se hace
a dos voces y está inserta una en frente
de otras y entonces se como una
resonancia en la forma de articular y
quién es la que pierde la primero que es
la que estuvimos ya pagando
bueno no estábamos vacante estábamos
trabajamos
es hermoso porque en verdad es además es
gracioso es gracioso este está pactando
esperando que sería la primera estás que
necesitan todos ruidos de animales de
todos los animales es difícil hay muy
bien en internet
el documental del que estoy hablando
están ahí en eso
leonardo micos e insólita que me pareció
muy chévere tan grande se tiene que ver
con la real policía montada de canadá si
es de la provincia de regina en la
provincia de saskatchewan entonces
resulta de que por allá hay aún un
centro para ancianos y en ese centro
para ancianos se festejaba el centén el
centésimo aniversario los 100 años de
una señora que estaba viviendo allí
gracia entonces la señora que estaba
viviendo allí para su aniversario número
ella quería bailar con un agente de la
real policía
su deseo de cumpleaños de 100 de 100
años
y no le mandaron solo uno le manda
comunicó el centro con el cuartel de la
policía montada en regina y les informó
no del deseo que tenía esta señora y
entonces pues los agentes que estaban
muy contentos dijeron que sí que iban a
participar y le dieron la sorpresa de
cumpleaños y el oficial que iba
representando a los que estaban ahí le
le le pidió permiso a su hijo fue a
verlo muy formal para decirle que sí si
podía invitar a bailar a su madre y el
hijo dijo que sí que sí que como no que
con mucho gusto entonces vino y sacó 100
años entonces la señora a sus 100 años
cumplió ese sueño que era de bailar como
un agente de la real policía montada
en julio así que bueno eso fue mi
insólito encontraste algo por ahí
no encontré el sonido de youtube
ayer 22 chicas puede ser esa la película
está está pero no saben no salir
[Música]
la coordinación que tienen voy a pasar
[Risas]
[Música]
no estamos acostumbrados nosotros
realmente de la garganta que es la
cronicidad con la que para eso ya no es
una presión entonces lo que estábamos
hablando mis estimados del canto de
garganta en nunavut que nos presentaba
como tema no como tema pero como algo
curioso y si les digo rápidamente el
título del documental que lo deseen y no
actitud saber cómo me sale bueno que
soltaba hablando y multitud en la lengua
entonces
me recuerda cuál es mi nombre en actitud
a la salud
[Música]
[Risas]
fue una señora indígena una viejita
verdad de una boutique y ya estábamos
entrevistando entonces me había dicho
que mi nombre era un personaje muy
conocido en nunavut también que se
llamaba para looks pero no me puedo
acordar en este momento voy a hacer para
luca entonces
otro nombre
yo sigo pensando en el chancho pero no
lo que dice la cultura y nuit es muy
interesante yo tuve la experiencia de
vivirla y un año algo definitivamente
inolvidable mamá
sí ahí estoy bien saludos
hoy acabo de hacer
todos los mensajes que tenemos mientras
leonardo busca a algunos de los césar
rodríguez charlie dice lo que no
comprende muy bien fue lo del mighty la
conciencia de los marranos la historia
era simple europea trata de buscarlo
para comentárselo es como que están
haciendo transplantes de células madre
cerebrales humanas en animales para
buscar con un fin determinado y lo que
comprobaron es que esas células madres
se acoplan al cerebro de la vida del
animal y dieron señas de las mismas
emisiones que uno a un ser humano le
hacen un electro en el programa con la
conciencia esas partes se iluminaron en
los animales también ya que podría hacer
que ese tipo de trasplantes
no sé si otorgada o activa la
consciencia pierde la conciencia de los
animales lo cual sería extremadamente
cruel 6 a mi juicio bien pero bueno
porque para un animal de
y digo tal vez es la solución para el
planeta no por nosotros las brutalidades
que hacemos nosotros con conciencia
imagínate si los animales con los
mensajes gonzález dice saludos desde
guadalajara aquí batallando por la
escasez de gasolina espero que el alumno
que estén bien todos ustedes amigos de
radio canal internacional
césar beber taca ser que dicen me
hicieron reír y 7 imagina si el chancho
es argentina por el trasplantado debería
siendo chanchadas lindo día para ustedes
manda saludos y saludos amigos así que
bueno esos son los comentarios que
tenemos hasta ahora de la gente que está
sintonizando nos en face bueno
muchísimas gracias muchísimas gracias
por esa alta fidelidad o que sea por
facebook caramba por cantera alta
fidelidad por ondas de radio pero césar
augusto charlie rodríguez se acuerda de
esa época gloriosa de la onda
yo creo que él sigue escuchando la onda
corta allá en bogotá colombia bueno
tenemos una paloma martínez méndez ha
sido con la música
ningún comentario aquí de héctor que
dice la mus sobre el reportaje la música
desafía al alzheimer y dice al escoger
la música se tiene que pensar en lo que
le gustaba a esa persona me imagino que
le sale esa persona eso le hará
reaccionar positivamente no soy
profesional médico pero mi instinto me
hace pensar así me imagino que el
reportaje trataba no sé si alguno de
ustedes lo hizo yo lo hice yo le avisé y
era una es una experiencia de una
investigación de la universidad mcgill
si no me equivoco que tienen una
expertise un desarrollo del tema en la
universidad mcgill que tiene pues fama
internacional ya y justamente si desean
cristian así y que se producen les hacen
escuchar música que ellos saben que le
gustaba de alguna manera antes de
enfermar porque lo que dicen es que esa
música activa en la persona recuerdos
entonces hay una reacción
hay una rejilla
entonces como te acuerdas es increíble
esa esa historia también a mí me pareció
siguiendo el tema del cerebro el que
realmente se activa la memoria porque
hay una memoria emocional que uno
conserva y que a través de la música la
música te hace reaccionar no no tiene
que ver con el alzheimer pero sí con
alguien que bueno en realidad no se sabe
en qué condiciones está pero hace un
poquitos días atrás una semana
aproximadamente cumplió 50 años michael
schumacher willi que está internado
no sabe una parte del artículo dice que
la gente le hace los que están
encargándose desde su recuperación o
desatención le pasaban sonidos de los
diferentes motores con los que él
condujo
así que yo creo que una reacción
emocional también si hay cosas que no
sabemos
pero todos cuando escuchamos cierto tipo
de música recordamos momentos de
nuestras vidas qué maravilla justamente
hay momentos que están marcados en mis
manos para eso están los boleros para
ciertas grasas y el tango
también encontrado bien bien entre
comillas porque tiene un significado
medio raro en la costa colombiana
el significado volvemos a los 30 minutos
yo tengo aquí un comentario sobre qué
bolsonaro el presidente de brasil prevé
recortar y privatizar programas
y que creo que esto no es lo único que
está pasando solo en brasil está pasando
en otros lugares y alberto escribe que a
alguien le dije que alguien le diga al
presidente que privatizar las pensiones
es robarles las pensiones a la gente
crean miseria futura y descontento
social tengo en mi mensaje el ejército
de canadá levantaría requisitos de
ciudadanía para aumentar sus efectivos y
carlos andrés henríquez enríquez ayala
dice soy abogado tengo 37 años soy
soldado de reservas deseo servir en el
ejército canadiense tengo vocación y
lealtad militar espero una respuesta
para empezar a realizar los papeles y
presentarme lo más pronto posible a
carlos andrés le decimos que bueno en
realidad me parece que es al revés
tendría que empezar a tramitar para
venir a canadá y luego para entrar en la
fuerza y todos los datos están en la
embajada canadiense en su país de origen
o bien en el sitio de inmigración canadá
bueno nosotros son huevos solo somos los
mensajeros así que no tenemos esa
información a mano
es siempre mejor ir a la fuente y la
fuente son las embajadas de canadá en
los distintos lugares aquí hay un
comentario con respecto a un tema vive
en zona de ruidos fuertes es una
pregunta eso puede provocar un ataque
cardíaco no sé quién lo hizo yo creo que
es bueno mira entonces jessica yañez
ramos cruz ella dice no dice dónde es no
dice de dónde es pero ella dice es bueno
saber esta noticia ya que conocemos el
riesgo que tenemos ante el ruido en la
población y así poder evitarlo juntos
para evitar enfermedades múltiples
entonces será un comentario de jessica
yañez rahm oscuros no sé desde donde nos
escribía jessica bueno el tiempo para
una segunda tanda versión que tengo aquí
un mensaje sobre el reportaje el día de
la libertad de prensa que fue este año
el 8 de enero
no creo no me suena que fue el 8 de
enero el día de la libertad de prensa
pero bueno el el reportaje y digo él en
un comentario siempre puede ser
de la virgen de la concepción día
mundial de la libertad de prensa dos
milésimas
dice voy a ser crítico y todavía sigo
sin creer como esté el señor donald
trump es presidente de un gran país como
eeuu siempre que leo alguna de sus
frases es como que me da muchísima rabia
pero bueno son ideales lópez mario nos
escribía con respecto el día de la
libertad de prensa un reportaje sobre
este tema
a que un comentario sobre justamente
este programa canadá en las américas
café escribe raúl alcalá debe ser de
españa me suena alcalá un amigo mío es
alcalá vive en san luis argentina así
que a lo mejor es talento es raúl no no
no a otro bueno hola amigos dice feliz
año nuevo por eso me gusta leerlo porque
están nos escriben a todo el equipo
espero que les vaya bien este nuevo año
y mi mayor deseo es que el 2019 les
traiga
prosperidad y mucha felicidad lo mismo
va entonces para raúl histórico de cosas
buenas nosotros tenemos otro comentario
dice bolsonaro abre territorios
indígenas a la actividad comercial y
santiago meses dice que triste el último
pulmón del mundo será explotado para
enriquecer a asia europa y norteamérica
y los latinoamericanos que nos contamos
dice dinero dinero y más dinero el
dinero no se puede plantar para hacer
crecer un árbol era el mensaje de santes
gómez muy bien yo tengo acá un
comentario investiguen en windsor
propiedades de una hierba mala para
curar el cáncer
richard caballero no richard cabello
montalvo dice muy interesante esta
noticia en perú existe hacer extracto de
la raíz con agua mineral agua no
procesada no con agua de caño hervir la
raíz con flores entonces pues eso el
comentario de richard cabello
de cabello montalvo que nos lleva a ese
a esa medicina tradicional no que es muy
latente y presente en nuestros países
cada vez más se llevan a cabo encuentros
entre las personas expertas de las
primeras naciones expertas en estos
temas con los médicos de la medicina
digamos tradicional canadiense
occidental perdón entonces porque se dan
cuenta de que es necesario intercambiar
mucho más porque las primeras naciones
tienen un conocimiento todo los
centrales de años que están practicando
entonces si se están aprovechando y me
parece que en américa latina también es
muy fuerte el tema de la utilización de
los yuyos las hierbas de eliminación
sobre todo también los yuyos los suyos
son plantas que crecen sin pastos que no
lo plantamos para nosotros
posiblemente es una palabra que he hecho
probable así
porque yo me recuerdo de que cuando era
chico allá en barranquilla colombia hace
muchísimos años de eso entonces cuando
entre los amigos le daban 1 agua y yo
pero entonces lo que decía que era guay
hubiera que todos los amigos llegaban y
te golpeaban la cabeza agua y huyó agua
yo te golpeó en la cabeza
cualquier tipo de hierba silvestre es el
suyo y yo muchos en américa del sur de
colombia y ecuador hierbas silvestres
que sirven como condimento para comidas
donde en color
[Risas]
vamos con los temas para variar un poco
y leonora tú nos habla de una nueva
perspectiva para los trabajadores
temporales que sufren abusos aquí en
canadá
justamente pablo y se trata de una
propuesta del gobierno canadiense que
llegan un momento y ese que los
trabajadores migrantes víctimas de
abusos en el trabajo podrían liberarse
pronto de los permisos de trabajos
restrictivos que vinculan su estatus en
canadá a los mismos empleadores que
justamente provocan esos abusos y es
importante esta noticia porque estamos
hablando de un poco más de 300.000
trabajadores temporales y cada vez
trabajadores de los cuales un poco más
de la mitad tienen ese tipo de contrato
deben ir a canadá específicamente a
trabajar un año dos años
un solo empleador lo cual se presta y se
prestó a muchos abusos por parte de los
empleadores y esto trae tiene un poco el
tema yo me imagino que ha ejercido
alguna influencia por ejemplo lo que
está mostrando aquí y leonardo ese
muchacho se llama juan godoy es un
trabajador temporal extranjero lo
entrevista lo entrevistamos varias veces
porque este caso tuvo una resonancia muy
fuerte en el país eran 14 trabajadores
guatemaltecos que cayeron en un lugar
específico en quebec para trabajar y que
sufrieron abusos de la tanto del
propietario del lugar como de una
persona ajena a ese trabajo pero que les
había ofrecido trabajar en otro lugar y
le sacó dinero y por supuesto que era
una estafa
ahora los la ley hasta hoy prohíbe en
canadá que un trabajador extranjero que
viene con un contrato específico pueda
cambiarse y buscar trabajo en otro lugar
o con otra empresa si le conviene si le
pagan mejor
estaba prohibido entonces por eso estos
14 guatemaltecos fueron detenidos en su
momento por haberse encontrado
trabajando en otro lugar y ellos
explicaron lo que había pasado que
habían sido estafados habían sido
maltratados y hubo un movimiento aquí en
que ve que se formó en defensa de estos
trabajadores tenían una abogada tenían
grupo sol y finalmente llegó después de
más de un año de un juicio que se
extendía
porque ellos le hicieron juicio también
nada como se llama este es un organismo
de protección de los trabajadores del
sindicato algo así
en todo caso si perdieron el juicio en
el mes de diciembre noviembre fines de
diciembre exactamente entonces juan
godoy este muchacho que estaba mostrando
aquí louis
decidió pues no esperar hasta que lo
expulsen porque sirvieron la orden de
expulsión y se fue hace dos semanas pero
además muy enojado que es sancionado
misma y muy enojado además con canadá ha
decepcionado con quebec por por todo
porque ellos dicen que ellos tenían
razón inició entonces con esta nueva ley
que el gobierno canadiense no sé si es
una ley es una propuesta de ottawa las
cosas van a cambiar entonces se piensa y
esta es una información que provenía del
toronto star y que después aprovechamos
para hacer una entrevista con un ex
trabajador temporal entraría
próximamente no va a tardar en entrar
pues en aplicarse esta ley lo cual pues
es creo que es una excelente noticia
para los que están ya trabajando acá y
para los próximos que vendrán y que se
van a saber que tienen derechos y los
propietarios y los dueños de las
empresas se van a cuidar muchísimo más
para no cometer abusos con esos
trabajadores porque los pueden perder ya
esperando también que se corrijan
errores no porque mucha gente como los
14 que se fueron están todavía uno se
fue juan godoy los otros tienen una
esperanza hicieron otra apelación pero
que hasta el momento nunca funcionó
entonces están intentándolo y las veces
esta ley haga que se les permita
quedarse en fin no sé ya esperamos que
se corrijan errores como decíamos y
leonardo el mensaje los mensajes acá
césar rodríguez jarr y volviendo a
hablan el género
la 'rebelión en la granja' 30 minutos
marta que se dicen los libros de corín
tellado al este recuerdo los monjes y me
acuerdo de los libros juan pablo
rodríguez y el habla de esos libros pero
dice touring sellado el día de la
inmaculada
esta virgen de la inmaculada concepción
del 8 de gracia y de césar rodríguez
charlize en colombia hay el pasto y cuyo
y quien come ese pasto
siquiera como el pasto que quiera comer
facto' kikuyo que le ve palante
ahora sí bueno entonces paloma martínez
tu nos hablas de una nueva ley también
que protege a los niños indocumentados
lo cual me parece falta y sí señor es
una ley que entró en vigor el año pasado
pero de la que se escuchó muy poco
hablar y como estoy más investigando el
caso de uno de tres hermanos que no
habían tenido la posibilidad de estudiar
durante ocho años tuvimos más
información nos comunicamos con un
especialista que estuvo siguiendo de
cerca todo el que a todos los casos
bueno no todos los casos pero digamos la
movilización alrededor de todos los
niños que no podían ir a la escuela o
que no cuyos padres no se atrevían a
llevarlos a la escuela inscribirlos a la
escuela documentos que estaban
indocumentados en el territorio
quebequense de la provincia de québec
entonces después de muchos años de lucha
digamos el logro
que el gobierno de quebec aprobara una
ley en la que se dice que todos los
niños cualquier niño todo niño cuyos
padres tengan residencia habitual en la
provincia de québec pueden estudiar
gratuitamente hasta el final de su
educación secundaria o hasta los 18 años
de edad como todos los niños
kenneth canadienses y quebequense pero
lo más importante de esto es
independientemente de su situación
migratoria
es decir los las autoridades escolares
no pueden preguntarle a los niños ni a
los padres su situación migratoria no le
pueden preguntar usted es residente o
están sus papeles de residencia no le
pueden pedir nada más que una prueba
notarios eso ya existe y existe
únicamente en toronto y no es una ley y
no es una ley ahí justamente la persona
que yo entrevisté me hizo que que
notábamos bien la distinción entre lo
que pasa en ontario en toronto
particularmente y en un consejo escolar
de toronto más precisamente y lo que
esta ley quebequense de toda la
de quebec tiene de novedoso entonces
ahora si cualquier persona que no tenga
documentos y que tenga hijos en edad
escolar puede llevarlos a la escuela los
puede inscribir a las autoridades no
pueden ni preguntarles su situación
migratoria ni transmitir esa información
diremos que se dan cuenta que el niño es
indocumentado por que por alguna razón
esas personas no pueden comunicar esta
información a ninguna otra autoridad ni
escolar ni migratón a convertirse en
delator
ahí es donde se aplique esa ley de
toronto que era más una política y
servido de acuerdo mutuo llamaba el
don't ask don't tell preguntas y no dijo
si se es claro en este caso se aplicaría
a la provincia que cambia cambia mucho
bien saco esto me va a pensar un poco
nunca al margen hablando de que canadá
se está quedando un poquito solo en el
mundo con este tipo de políticas
dirigidas al y hacia los indocumentados
en general si observamos lo que pasa en
eeuu que están cerrando las puertas si
quiero crear muros
pero además en europa todo lo que están
los países de derecha en europa que
están queriendo prohibir directamente a
la inmigración a sus países y estaba
leyendo algo que es preocupante decía
que merkel la canciller angela merkel
que se dijo que ya no se presenta en las
elecciones la derecha ya se está
moviendo velozmente en alemania para
tratar de ganar las próximas elecciones
y eso va a ser otro drama sin hablar de
lo que están haciendo en argentina
cerrando las puertas tambalearse
y se está quedando aislado en este
momento canadá tal vez a más acompañado
con mexico en el momento que ofreció a
las caravanas a las personas dentro de
las caravanas migrantes viniendo de
américa central que se podían quedar por
lo menos un año en territorio mexicano
obteniendo un permiso de empleo y de
estancia temporal a todos aquellos que
lo quisieran así muy bien
leonardo gimeno tú
te haces una pregunta con respecto a
facebook que instagram a algo muy
popular que estamos viendo ahora por las
redes y que las preguntas están
manipulando a los usuarios con este
famoso desafío del décimo aniversario es
este es el tema que tiene que ver con
bueno nos encantan las teorías de
conspiraciones a mí me encantan
particularmente las que tienen que ver
con la tecnología y en este caso de la
teoría conspiratoria margen de las
ventajas
puntualmente en este caso salió hace
tres o cuatro días atrás el challenge
una vez por año hay un chal en el
banquete se acuerda en el del cubo de
agua fría que era fama coronada por
definida pero bueno salieron un montón
de charlene
a partir del 2016 dos o tres por años
salen en este caso salió el tender
change
el resto de los otros diez años y era
como poner una foto personal de su
rostro del 2009 y uno del 2019 para ver
el cambio del que había pasado en estos
diez años lo gracioso es que no lo hizo
un montón de cosas
diría mi hija me reta que digo me
también dos personas particularmente una
fue walt mossberg un prestigioso
periodista igual street journal que
salió diciendo yo no me pegó a esta me
parece que hay algo de fondo en el
trasfondo descuentos si no no se sabe si
hay algo cerrado aquí esto no le diremos
nada
la periodista kate o'neal del sitio wire
que es un sitio que hace críticas de
cuestiones tecnológicas dio un tweet muy
particular diciendo que este tipo de
fotos podría ser
a los algoritmos de reconocimiento
facial a que sean más familiares para
aprender digamos la posibilidad el
cálculo para ver cómo evoluciona tu
rostro de ahora adentro de 10 años fue
un lapso de 10 años entonces dijo la
mujer está yo tampoco comparte ese tipo
de fotos porque en realidad hay fotos
nuestras en las redes sociales de hace
10 años pero lo que estamos haciendo
nosotros es facilitándoles la
computadora
y facebook acá se está en un par de
meses atrás él mandó un comunicado
interno que fue recuperado por walt
mossberg diciendo que
estaban desarrollando un nuevo
reconocimiento facial para poder ser
etiquetado en fotos donde uno no se
reconoce o sea la herramienta es
poderosísima animal pero la gente que
está en las conspiró gracias hablan de y
bueno no será para poder identificarnos
en cualquier momento en un lugar como
está pasando en china ahora exacto que
se han basado que han combinado la
información que es exacta sexy accesible
perdón en los sitios de medios sociales
con la combinación que la policía tiene
al utilizar estos lentes de texto a la
cara ahora imagínate bozo hace poco
tiempo leí que hubo un famoso
narcotraficante que se me escapa el
nombre que se hizo la cirugía estética
cómo hacen para detectarlo a él sí para
se le pone en el aparato y dado contra
fiorentina
bueno bueno muy bueno estamos siendo
investigados una vez más
no compartan más
de lo que yo invito a escuchar de su
reportaje que hice es una noticia de un
descubrimiento mayor que se hizo aquí en
quebec en la universidad laval el centro
de investigación
de esta universidad que descubrió que
con una prueba de saliva se puede hacer
una prevención precoz del cáncer de mama
en las mujeres si lo dice entonces que
me parece súper interesante porque él
dice además sin pasar por esos famosos
test ni parece son dolorosos y esto nos
dice que las mamografías van a continuar
solo con la prueba de saliva se va a ir
y se puede hacer la prevención
van más joven o sea parece que esa gente
entre los 59 y los 60 y tantos años no
encuentro aquí la información
69 creo que que se hacen estas las
mamografías y él dice de que con la
prueba de saliva se puede empezar a de
empezar antes a los 40 100 años que bien
bien dice que este este esta prueba de
saliva en la forma como funciona es que
pudieron estudiar 12 millones de
marcadores
evidentemente estábamos hablando de algo
ritmos ahorita y de tecnología pues las
nuevas tecnologías justamente las te
permiten además de identificar a las
personas
este tipo de investigaciones no
invasivas
12 millones de marcadores genéticos y
encontraron que esa prueba el del cáncer
de mama tiene una firma genómica de 313
marcadores entonces ya están
identificados cuando se le hace la
prueba de la saliva si los 313
marcadores
entonces se puede hacer la prevención
con mucho antes que a los 40 años en vez
de comenzar a escuchar el reportaje en
nuestro sitio internet ahí están todos
los detalles dice que se validó este
estudio se hizo en 170 mil
incluyendo 95 mil mujeres que sufrían de
cáncer de mama y después que obtuvieron
esta firma genómica de 313 marcadores lo
validaron con 200.000 mujeres más
es una buena meta entonces eso en
nuestros internet y bueno
desafortunadamente se nos está yendo
antes carlos rodríguez charlie dice es
el pasto de los jardines en bogotá un
pasto invasor traído hace años cuando
hablábamos del parque
maría herrera dice nuevamente
compartiendo con ustedes los hermosos
temas abordados siempre presente desde
san luis argentina maría también hacía
rato que no la veíamos pero ahora está
nuevamente con nosotros
es cumpleaños de mi hija
16 años imagínate en esta mesa para los
que no saben y aquí entre nosotros nada
más
el mío me mate o es el mayor tiene 19
años después está el mateo está siendo
16 años hoy y estaba de moda no sabía
cuando yo voy a trabajar acá estaba
embarazada no sabe qué pasó cuando yo
comencé a trabajar acá hacía una semana
que había nacido mi hijo bueno entonces
en los controles técnicos hoy sanxenxo
ver aquí en el estudio paloma leonora
leonardo que menos le quiero recordar
que la versión audio de este programa
podrán escuchar también la música de
patricia cano que es una chica
hoy ontario de origen peruano que tiene
muy bonita música medio jazzeada y todo
esto y bueno pues la van a poder
escuchar en el programa grabado eso fue
todo por hoy
gracias siempre adiós la semana próxima
más bien chao